the film second major destination was
the African nation of Kenya where one
incredible woman has spent her life
rescuing baby elephants and helping them
return to the wild Daphne Sheldrick has
been working with elephants for over 50
years there lots of magic places in
Kenya right from the start I've been
amongst animals and loved them all at
that time Kenya was much wilder they
were wild animals all around Kenya is a
place which has suffered tremendous
environmental degradation as indigenous
people use whatever resources are around
and to try to change the level of their
lifestyle I think everyone should really
be aware of the natural world and do
what they can to protect and preserve it
Daphne's husband David started what
became the biggest national park of
kenya that place is the shelter for the
largest loud herds of elephant that are
left in Kenya when David first went
there there wasn't even a road and there
wasn't anything so he built that park
literally from nothing the Sheldrick
Wildlife Trust has anti-poaching patrols
removing snares all over Tsavo National
Park they maintain fences to help keep
people out
we seem to have gone wrong somewhere
there are so many poor people in Africa
that they will be tempted to kill an
elephant for its ivory preserving the
ones that are left is a tremendous
responsibility the elephants have a very
human intelligence and a lot of
abilities that we actually lack spending
five weeks now with these elephants
there's a part of me that's been changed
by being with them because they're
amazing every single species contributes
towards the well-being of the planet as
a whole it's the only place we have and
we've got to take care of it
you